oh il vient d'une autre planète les
extraterrestres
le basketball sera le sport le plus
populaire du monde au 21e siècle
déclaration de David Stern dans mondial
basket David qui dirige la NBA depuis 10
ans la NBA c'est la fédération de
basketball professionnel américain on
peut pas refaire mieux pour le sport
spectacle avec des noms qui font rêver
les gamins et les autres Johnson bird
Jordan et aujourd'hui il y a Shaquille
O'Neal Johnson Charles Barclay et les
autres bien sûr la NBA c'est 100% pro
c'est du spectacle pur jus avec des
joueurs qui viennent carrément d'une
autre planète Alexandre Boyan
bienvenue dans le monde de l'incroyable
que l'on mesure à mettre 58 ou de mettre
30 on s’y côtoie on y est annulé c'est
vrai qu'en NBA on fait tout pour se
faire remarquer rien n'est laissé au
hasard pub est marketing sur le même
terrain intérêt commun dans ce n'est pas
un univers impitoyable mais ça surprend
c'est impressionnant dans l'organisation
parce que moi je regarde un peu de tous
les côtés regard curieux mais attention
on veille à la Ligue américaine de
basket c'est une véritable
multinationale pour que le message passe
il faut atteindre sa cible et en NBA on
échouera rarement
il vient d'une autre planète
quand les extraterrestres débarquent
dans un autre pays que le leur il faut
le faire savoir et bien évidemment on y
met la manière bonjour
poli bien habillé disponible il faut se
montrer sympathique se montrer tout
court aujourd'hui bien sûr à la
télévision sur tout la télé-rolet
indispensable de la NBA qui a sa propre
maison de production mais il faut aussi
s'entraîner seul point qui n'a pas
changé parce que pour le reste Robert
Paris 18 saisons en pro et pluvieux
joueurs
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ça se développe en dehors
c'est plutôt une bonne chose pour vous
bon pour les non américains à condition
d'y mettre le prix et beaucoup de zéro
les matchs ont retransmis dans environ
140 pays à travers le monde et puis les
ventes des produits au consommateur
atteignent quand même des chiffres bruts
d'environ près de 3 milliards de dollars
mayoub ballon panier sous licence NBA
l'offre est bien là la demande aussi
vous pouvez trouver une casquette à 99
francs comme une belle brodée très
travaillée je sais pas comme celle-ci
par exemple qui a presque 200 francs un
petit peu moins bon c'est tout dépend
des modèles c'est très variable c'est le
prix du rêve américain le rêve américain
je sais pas si cher que ça
le rêve américain c'est bien sûr la
dream team mais après les arrêts de
Jordan Johnson et burn on recherche de
nouvelles stars les publicités aussi il
y a Barclay le dernier dinosaure des JO
chaque îlotil et sa puissance Bob et ses
158 cm et puis il y a Larry Johnson un
contrat en or de 425 millions de francs
pour 14 ans là dedans peut relire et le
joueur se doit de briller pour payer
tout ça il y a le public encore et
toujours à Bercy les places à l'aide de
180 à 330 francs s'il faut marquer des
paniers dans le basket la NBA s'est
décidément comment les remplir
super peut-être un petit peu cher les
places 330 francs mais enfin quand on
aime on casse acquérir de temps en temps
ça tirelire de temps en temps
[Musique]